good morning we have our eyes on two  slow zones but i have good news for you  we go down first to the southeast where  we have a crash that's still there 215  westbound on green valley parkway the  good news is  it's off to the right shoulder so that  should be clearing out soon  this one though it's really slowing  people down this is on northbound 95  before las vegas boulevard as we take a  live look of the area we see  those cars on the right side hey  northbound really moving  really really slowly but the good news  is that the crash from earlier this  morning that was blocking center lanes  is finally out of the way have a great  tuesday